all right let's just say at that time
it's me it's gotta gutter it's tiger
it's wayne it's drake is mac man it's
nikki
before we even go in the booth
we're gonna say our verse for everybody
hmm
in a circle turn that turn that down
real quick i get
everybody like this
i don't think we're the only crew that
used to function like that
i think before you go on the booth cam
wanted to hear your [ __ ] too right and
cam gonna be brutally honest and wayne
gonna be it was times
some people might not make it to a song
it was songs i didn't make it to because
wayne might hear that [ __ ] and be like
nah
you cannot
oh he might get to the studio and we
already didn't put verses on [ __ ] before
he got there he played back listen to it
but like
oh oh nah nails gotta gotta kill you on
that one
take that verse off right
[ __ ] i'm gonna say
yeah at that point it's like okay we
probably about to do eight more records
tonight you're not thinking you're not
thinking about it like that when you're
in that crew mode and you and that it's
my [ __ ] we bombing on we just bombing
on [ __ ] you know what i'm saying you're
not thinking like that and i think tde
he wasn't thinking like that q ain't in
there with ab soul and kendrick and all
of them when they was doing their thing
right it's like
you're just bombing on [ __ ] you're just
bombing on [ __ ]